bootleg cat podcast man special guests
in the building about to do what he does
my crazy roll real quick brother shout
out to ig shout out where they could uh
go stream your [__] out now what's going
on what's going on my crazy real
underscore on everything man I'm gang
Long Beach in the [__] house
the Long Beach let's get to it man hit
that beat bruh
[Music]
oh
Shane ain't trying to hear these fake
[__] I can hear it and my ears spent a
long time trying to Boiling now I'm here
[__] I love and disappear hey coming
life is all part of the trip keep on
grinding to them girls you trying to
this [__] get hard stick to the script
remember to be heartless in this [__]
cause there's some people trying to turn
this what you did hard truth don't let
the Judgment turn you to a minute stay
gonna talk try to expose you when they
[__] [__] [__] you I just took a l to
take a w I win a empty down my place to
get a better view I'm in hey trying to
up the stakes to build some Revenue
Williams hey I feel like I miss I feel
so good when I commit hey can you be my
ride or die that does not exist hey Auto
Body out of mind my experience hey
Audemars don't tell the time stop for my
wrist hey expect me one day imma
diefully a trip
[Music]
hey respect me one day Imma die like
really a trip
expect one day Imma die this [__] ain't
easy when you come up just a little po
chasing your dreams keep buying with the
hustle getting low act like you see me
in support but [__] really don't lose
so much hate up in my city feeling
Mutual cannot participate in fraud that
your [__] post not at all the type of
guy falls them people know I'm in a cat
how am I doing on the phone these [__]
prayed on my damn phone look who on the
floor by the glasses spread me about
five pounds to see you go stalking look
me in my eyes you've done that shit's
fault we hit the set to catch a vibing
this back to the old that little [__]
stay in my mind she get the best to
throw
oh all right bro Long Beach man that's
how y'all coming let's go and appreciate
it appreciation
yes sir go follow them my crazy world
underscore right yep on everything go
run it out new music out too hey I know
you just watched the new freestyle guess
what we're dropping them every week
sometimes more than once a week Jesus
we've been dropping a lot lately uh
shout out to LRG don't forget go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week